Chris Rob plans to push the limits
during his hosting duties at the 88th
annual Academy Awards as several
minority actors boycott the Oscars for
its lack of diversity
he sat down with the show's producer
Reginald Hudlin at the n-double-a-cp
Image Awards nominee luncheon to find
out what viewers can expect from the
comedian chris is very excited he's not
dropping out oh no oh no chris is hard
at work he's literally Deanna's right
instead they've locked themselves in a
room he actually wrote the show about a
week ago really and then as things got a
little provocative and exciting he said
I'm going out to show I wrote and I'm
writing a new show because Chris is that
thorough he's that brilliant
and I have 1,000% confidence that you
deliver something that people will be
talking about for weeks but is the
academy ready for what Chris Rock will
bring I'm expecting something bananas
that would be correct you should expect
that and yes the Academy is ready for
him to do that they're excited about him
doing that they know that's what we need
we know that's what the public wants and
we deliver what the people want so
basically what you're saying is tuned in
oh yeah I mean are you gonna be that
person the next day that's like what
happened